Hey, Austin, good afternoon.
Hey, Austin.
Good afternoon.
You're speaking.
Sorry for running late. Yeah, we guys muted. Sorry, gentlemen. Hey, Kip, how you doing? Oh, is it Sarjeet? Am I saying that right? Sarjeet?
You?
No worries.
Yes, yes, you got that right, Austin.
Yeah.
Okay, wonderful.
Wonderful.
All right, I...
I believe we are connecting for the first time.
We are, yes, yes, we are. I apologize for running late, but yes, we are.
Kip.
No worries, no worries, completely understandable. I was just talking to Kip to drop you an email. So Austin, just a quick introduction. I'm the CX, I'm the customer success manager for the partnership which we have with ITBD. In total, I have got around 2 decades of work experience and from last 9 1/2 years I have been working with IT by design.
Okay.
Prior to moving into the CX role, I was working with the service delivery team. So feel free to reach out to me in case if there is anything where you need any assistance. And talking about the relationship which I have with CNW, I share a long bond with Dana, with Eric.
I'm not sure you are not there. We started with one of an old engineer, it was Nate, even before Vaughn, when he joined the team and I was managing, I was working along with Eric. So it's a pleasure to meet you, Riz.
Okay.
It's nice to meet you as well, yes.
And are you located in the same office?
Sorry, I just got done, I just got, I am, yeah, I just got done working out and I haven't had time to change back into my work outfit, but yeah, sorry for that guys.
Perfectly okay. At least you are able to get some time out for your workouts. That's more important.
Yeah, that helps, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, I apologize. I know I've missed the last two of these, but so I'm here and Halo's going live. That's kind of sucked up a lot of my time. So I appreciate your guys' patience with me on that. And I'm ready when you are.
Yep, so how are things going with one?
Uh, they're going, they're going well with Vaughn. I know that I gave you, um, is it last week or two weeks ago? I'm trying to remember. Um, kind of like a project that would like start rolling out for Microsoft Defender.
Yeah.
Yes.
And what we want that to look like and feel like, because we can't just flip a switch, but we really want our clients to know what that will detail for them, what they'll see, what are differences they might experience, such as a phishing button or a spam button, and what are the differences for them. If they do get a quarantine message, right, like how do they check quarantine?
Yeah.
How do they log in and see that items that are quarantined and on quarantine or say, no, this is definitely you should have quarantined this. It's important that we.
We know we provide the value of showing what we're doing for them and how we're keeping them safe. And so, yeah.
Yeah.
So when we are planning to push this project?
Well, when you guys tell me you have kind of a game plan, we'll review it and then we'll sign a client to it, maybe like a five-person client, push it out, let them know what's going on with it. You know, as part of our ongoing services, we're providing the service for you to help, you know, ensure a better protective security portfolio.
portfolio kind of a deal. And then we'll just say, this is what, these are the changes that will occur for you. You now have the ability to right-click and set, you know, go to phishing or spam. Even though they've already, they've always had this ability, now they'll know what these buttons really do, right? Yeah, I'm going to right-click, send to junk.
S.
Mm.
or there's a difference between sending it to junk and spam and deleting it. There's all these differences, so it's good that they know. And then how they get to quarantine. And you know, the capabilities of.
I think Defender lets you do, lets you do standard, I'm going to call it standard risk and high risk. I don't think that's what they call it. I think they call it standard and high. I'm trying to think, but just so our clients can know the differences and if they ever need, oh, you know, I think our CFO should be looked at more than our standard users. Let's make sure he's got more things and we want to do that as well.
Ch.
Sure. So what I will do is I will work with Juan and we'll share the discover work or the plan for the project with you or the email, like how it's going to happen and how we are going to implement it. And then we can work with one of the client and then we can roll out to the others.
Okay.
Yep, sounds good.
Yeah.
And Kip, just a suggestion in the interim, while you are going to coordinate with one, can we have some piece of documentation which we can share with Austin to ensure that this is something which we can share with the stakeholders?
Yeah, that.
Yes, that's what I'm talking about. So I will work with one and create the documentation, like the scope of work or the whole, the plan that we are going to implement. And that will be on the documentation and we'll share that with you. You will review it. And once you approve it, then we will work with one of the clients for the implementation.
Okay, yeah, so perfect. Yeah, get me that, I'll review it, and then we'll probably have a meeting of if I have any changes or additions or ask why you're doing something a certain way, and then make sure we understand where we're going there. And I am very big on, like, it's, you know, like, hey, I'm going to give you this. You come back with a rough draft or first draft for me.
Yeah.
So because I can do first drafts all day, every day, but that's not my job anymore. I give you, you do first draft, rough draft, you come to me and then we'll solidify it and maybe we do another draft after that. And then we put it into play. And then it's our current goal line for every client here going forward. It's got his name on it and your name on it and it's...
Yep, absolutely.
part of our repertoire.
Yep, absolutely understand. Yeah, sounds like a plan.
Ketan.
Okay.
So what else? Anything else? Any other feedback you would like to share from one?
No, no, no, he's doing really well with Halo. I'm sure he's told you about it. Or you, you know, maybe you've seen a little bit of a difference. And the next thing I get to do this month is get my reporting down in place of...
What are the SOPs, kind of like what you were asking about?
Mhm.
two months ago when I was in the thick of it. And then I can say, okay, this is what we're doing for, this is what we're going for. And then so by our next meeting, I'll have that data for you. So we can have a hard set data of what we're looking for, what our target goal should be. And the only thing with Vaughn is, and this is not.
Yeah.
Okay.
Again, this is what he was used to before I came here, which was, hey, I did the work, I'm going to close the ticket out. I did the work, I'm going to close the ticket out. But now our policy is a little bit different and sometimes he's really, really good on it, but sometimes there's a little slip of, hey, I did the work, but now it's just a follow up, make sure that the client knows we did the work.
and either get a response. If we don't get a response, then we put it into the three strike rule, and then we let the system tell us, hey, you went through three strikes, you can just close it out from here on out. We did what we had to do, and then close it out. So it leads to a little bit longer retention of tickets, but ensures our customer quality service is a higher standard than.
Hey, I fixed it and then we don't get those callbacks about, this wasn't fixed, who said that's fixed, right? Like, you know.
Sure, sure. Definitely I will share that with Juan and we'll ensure that he follows the same. So with that being said, let me quickly share my screen and let's go through the presentation deck.
Yeah.
Perfect.
And let me know once you're able to see my screen.
I see it.
Okay, great. So once again, welcome to our monthly business review and this is from 6th March till 1st May.
And agenda would be the same. We will start with check-in, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of a customer, way forward and recap.
So we already talked about how things are going with one and yeah, so thank you for sharing the feedback. We appreciate it.
So these are some highlights we from based on our previous connects. So we discussed Juan's performance and the assigned projects. He's improving in the ticket closure quality and getting positive client feedback. You also emphasized on capturing technical details like
and more details in his ticket notes and I hope he is doing the same.
And you also highlighted for stronger documentation habits on all tickets. And we also discussed about the escalation expectations, like he should escalate whenever he's unable to dissolve the ticket, rather than just keeping him, keeping that ticket with him.
And also follow the three strike rule as you just said.
Right.
And this is the Microsoft Dipon implementation we discussed about. So we will share the plan with you and then we will go from there.
Perfect.
And regarding the hello migration, are we still in the process or is it completed?
We're basically done. There's a few more, there's little bits here and there that'll probably drag on for three to four months, but yeah, we're fully in it, we're fully active in it, we're fully using it. Just some things that I gotta...
figure out on my end of how are we going to roll it out. But other than that, yeah, we're good. We're basically live. I'd say we're 85%.
Okay.
able to use the product.
Yeah, the reason I'm asking, because we discussed about the KPIs alignment for one sometime back before this hello migration started, and we agreed that once this hello migration is completed, we will discuss about the KPIs alignment for one. So just wanted to know, do you have...
anything in mind that we can, any KPIs, any that we can, using which we can measure one's performance, like utilization or SLAs or anything.
Not at the moment, like I said, like...
Yeah, at the beginning, I remember I kind of went through, hey, that's my goal this month. So by the time we have our next call, I'll have this data for you that you're looking for.
Okay. Okay, correct.
Yeah.
And the CX survey for the month of April has already been sent, so keep an eye on.
I missed it. I apologize. Yeah. You know, it's weird when it comes. I always think it's, I guess, to be honest, I always think it's spam. So I apologize for that. ITBD. Where did it go?
It was a monthly feedback for one.
Yeah.
Or if you would like, we can resend it too. Bring it on top of your inbox.
We appreciate pressure building it together. It's how are we doing, right? One minute feedback request, that's the one you're talking about? Yeah.
Yes, that's the one.
Do you call it this way for everybody? How are we doing? One minute feedback request.
There are two, Austin, just to keep you informed. One is the monthly CSAT, which is specifically for one. So the subject line would say monthly feedback for one. It will have three smileys, positive, neutral, or negative, and then space for the comments. Then the second which we send out, that's our NPS. That's like a.
Mhm.
quarterly survey. It's not only for one, it's for the overall services. If you would like, you can share the screen. We can just make sure that we are doing the right one. But most of the time for the LPS survey, we send it out to Eric.
So.
Got Team, okay.
For the monthly piece that we send it out to you because you are working directly with one.
No, yeah.
Mm.
Yep, no, I got here. It just, it's no matter what happens, because it says partner feedback, I always think of something else. So if it said like ITBD, I'd probably see it better than just saying partner feedback, just because we are, we have so many, we have so many different vendors that we deal with. So when I see partner feedback.
Okay.
Noted, and that's a good suggestion.
Yeah.
I think it, I don't think it was important. Not, it's not you guys, it's just what I'm used to seeing. So, okay.
The.
Perfectly understandable, Austin. Every single day we get so many emails. So I'll share the suggestion. It's a good one. Instead of having monthly feedback, we can just add in ITBD monthly feedback for the engineer. So that at least it's easier for the rest of our partners too.
Yeah, I know.
Yeah.
To find it, yeah, yeah.
Yep.
Okay, I have officially done that.
Okay, so Von is done. Thank you.
Okay, great. Thank you. Thank you, Austin. Really appreciate it. Moving on to the action tracker, Juan is working on his level up to advanced administrator, which he will be completing by the mid of June.
Mhm.
And then we have the ITBD recommended KPIs. We discussed about these some time back. But definitely, I'm sending you this PPT as well at the end of this call. You can go through these.
Okay.
ITBD recommended KPIs, and if you see there are some that can align with Vaughn's performance, so we can definitely start capturing that using hello reporting tools and all.
Let's jump into performance for Vaughn. This is his performance for the last four weeks, starting with 66%, then 68, 69, and he's been pretty consistent. His average utilization had been 68% for these four weeks. He's pretty close to the target, 80%, so improving a little bit.
He will definitely reach his target.
Okay.
And moving on to his ticket data, his average closure is at 84%. So in total, he worked on 237 tickets and close to 100 of them. So in every week, he was able to exceed a 40 ticket benchmark. So it is a good.
Yeah, that's a good target and it's a good goal and he hits it, he crushes it.
Yeah.
And way forward, we discussed in our last connect, so to create KBs for the complicated issues or unique issues he worked on. So again, it's part of the documentation part we discussed in our first slide highlights. So we will ensure he is working on the same.
Yeah, I'm trying to see if...
So, this is the...
Our system doesn't tell me.
Hello!
Go ahead, go ahead.
Yeah, so this is the AI by design.
So, sir, you want to take a...
Let me help you out over here. Perfect. You can stop the screen sharing Kip if we have covered everything. So a few things, Austin, just to keep you informed. Though Eric is already a part of our AI initiative, so for the month of August, we are going to hold our annual event.
Oh, okay, got it. Yeah.
Okay.
that is known as Build IT Live. So that's our 8th event in series. Let me bring it up on the website so that I can share more details. Eric is already registered for this event. In addition to that, he has already been actively participating. So this is where the more the merrier I would say. So I'll.
wanted to make sure that you have the information available. So if you would like to tag along with Derek, feel free to let me know. I'll drop him a text or if you would like, you can share it with him. So this year, we are hosting this event in New Jersey. That's Hyatt Regency for three days. That's August 3rd, 4th, 5th.
OK.
Even for our partners, we have on August 2nd, we have one pre-event as well. And on August 5th, which is the last day, we are going to have the AI discussions where whatever the innovations, the automations, which we have already implemented, we have the digital dispatcher, we have the L1 agents that has been developed.
for our partners specifically, which are the custom agents. The last call which I had with Eric, it was regarding the QBR automation so that you can reach out to your end users or the partners for your quarterly reviews too. So this is about the date, then what the event is all about.
more than 550 plus attendees would be there, 70 plus channel influencers would be participating, 50 plus tools and templates, the processes which we have already inbuilt, inculcated into our system that will be shared with the partners, 0 sales pitches. Talking about the speakers, we will have John C. Maxwell, Dan Sullivan,
and the industry leaders from different MSPs will be joining in. The focus as of now, it's more on monetization of the AI for our business growth, how you can scale sustainability and intelligently. The EBITDA enterprise value, so the team will be working on creating custom dashboards as well, AI leadership strategy.
Khan.
And then the MSP tools, which I have already talked about. The ticket is priced at 1495 for our early bird or the partners. We have the BOGO offer. I'll put the code in the chat for you. So let's say in case if you would like to bring along someone, it will be half the price.
Yeah.
And as Eric has already registered, so in case if more members should be coming in from your organization, you can just drop me a text. I'll talk to my leadership team and see in case if we can get some more discounted rate. These are some of the industry leaders who will be coming in. Habib Malik from MSP Corp from Thrive.
from logically from Red Helm who will be participating as speakers. And this is the venue. This is for the third day specifically. We are taking our partners for the...
for the event. That's New York Stock Exchange. Prior to this, we were able to take our partners to NASA. We booked the MetLife Stadium, so we were able to take it to the Statue of Liberty as well. So this time it's New York Stock Exchange, where the party team will be on Great Gatsby. So you have plenty of time to get your tuxedos ready.
Ketan.
Rest, if there is any other queries, you can always reach out to me. So think of me as a part of your extended team. I'm sending out the link for your reference so that you can go through the details. And I'll also, once Kip will send you the deck, I'll also.
Yeah, right.
Key.
share some additional information, probably like a single pager, which will be beneficial for you.
Okay.
Perfect. Let me put the code as well so that if you would like to go for the discounted price, you will be able to do so. In the referral, you can add my name if you will be going ahead with the registration. Here is the code. That's BOGO BOGO 1495. I have put it in the text window for you in the chat window.
Thank you, I see that. Thank you.
Perfect. Anything else where you think that our assistance is required, whether it's project, whether it's NOC services, SOC, we have plenty of other services for our partners. So you are not limited with code.
No, I just have a, I do have a general question which is, so Von's been asking about...
Mmh.
Mhm.
Up, so I know.
when you've been doing it as long as I think Von's been doing it, 10, 15 years, right? You kind of get that, that itch to be like, I'm ready to do something greater now, right? So, and I understand that, right? So that's why I'm like trying to give him this project, right? Like, because I think one thing in his skill set is, hey, if I'm, your boss gives you a project.
True, true.
Team.
What does that look like? Do you have those skills? If not, then let's build up those skills for you. That's not the same as a server build, but it is skills. The idea is I'd love Vaughn to stay on board, right? But I'm not blind to what Vaughn wants to do and what I can provide and what I can't provide.
Mhm.
So I want to make sure one, Vaughn is happy and Vaughn's good, but if there is a potential...
Yep.
What do I say here? If there is an availability for Vaughn to do something great in his life, there will be no hard feelings, especially with you guys in ITBD. All I ask is that you guys can be someone just as good as Vaughn if and when that comes. But if we can keep him with filling a different role for him, maybe that he can
Yeah.
Mhm.
he can be, see, he's still be happy with, then I'd like to make sure that that's possible for him. We just don't do a lot of servers. We just, maybe at one point they did here, and the idea is for us to not really get away from them, but the idea is to go more SharePoint side more, and our clients that we have here are small, medium business, and whatever.
In.
S.
The pricing comes up with.
cloud pricing for servers, everyone gets sticker shock. They're like, oh my God, sticker shock, right? So we're just trying to, I want to be realistic with his expectations. He's told me this a few times, which I appreciate, and I want him to be on board. I also don't want someone to be miserable at work.
S.
Namit.
Mhm.
Right? Nobody wants that. So that's like this project, I think will be a real good shoe in for him to be like, okay, I could do this. I enjoyed it. It was good. It was off the beaten path of what I'm normally doing. And what else you got for me after this? I was saying, great. Now it's.
Now it's implement this for everyone. Great, that was your project. You implement this for all clients. Next step is, let's work on this for all of our clients. And you do the same thing, build a project out, build a scope out, get it to me. Austin, I think is, and I, you know, then I can just let him go. Right.
Thank you, first of all, Austin. I'm glad that you are addressing this. That's really candid feedback for us too, and I appreciate that. So coming in from engineer perspective, we all know that yes, everyone wants to have some more kind of challenging task assigned to them.
Kip.
But that does not mean that I'll ask my guys to go, okay, now you would like to try, now go ahead and try to fly this airplane. So I'll ask him to hold on to his horses, let him trained on these things first. So Kip, probably we can take it internally.
Right, right, right, right.
It makes me.
Yeah.
Mhm.
you, Amit, can have a one-on-one discussion. Obviously, even we want that the kind of partnership which we have with C&W, that should not get impacted simultaneously. We need to also focus on the career growth path for Vaunt so that he should also feel that he's being aligned with the challenging task. In case if it's not with Austin, he's already taking care of the things.
Yeah.
Right.
particularly aligning one on the current project which he has. However, for long run, something we should have as a plan of action for us. So probably, Austin, we can take it along with our return team internally. Rest, if there is anything at all where you think.
Mhm.
Okay.
that we can utilize one, not specifically on the server side, probably Azure, even in the SharePoint migration, you have got plenty of things where we can utilize him. Or now he's been there in the system for such a long time. We also want to make sure that we are able to utilize his skill set effectively.
Right.
Yeah.
not just dealing with the...
the L1 kind of task. So, and in case if there is any need, though I don't think, but just to make sure that we have got all our ducks in thorough. So if there is any need where we think that, okay, if something would be at stake, we will make sure that you have a different engineer.
Right. Agreed.
who will be of the same caliber because right now our focus is more aligned for the Helpdesk assistance. So probably we'll work out some plan and then we can think about it during our upcoming calls. But thank you. Thank you for bringing this to our attention. Thank you.
Okay.
Yeah, no, I appreciate that. Yeah, you.
Of course, yeah. And, you know, Andy's got a new baby on the way, and I appreciate that. And I know, you know, as a dad, that puts a little fire on you as well, right? That you want to, you want to, you're ready, you're ready to go, go, go. So I appreciate you guys. Thank you.
Cruz.
Thank you. Kip.
Yeah, and even if you share any of these kind of projects with Juan, so I mean we have plenty of resources to help him out. I can help him out. We have plenty of resources internally in ITBD. So don't worry about it. So we will take care of everything.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, no, I appreciate it, guys. Aubrey.
S.
And just to add on to Kip's point, Austin, though I know we want to make sure that one is feeling challenged with the task which we are assigning to him. However, we have dedicated project teams as well. Let's say in case if you would like, let's say whether it's server migration, SharePoint migration, even Hello PSA, a backups migration. So we can go on a call separately where we can decide.
Okay.
the scope of work, the number of hours being utilized, and then these engineers can take care of those tasks specifically for you, ensuring that rest of the things are being taken care by the Helpdesk team specifically. So we do have the NOC services, we do have the SOC services, and then the dedicated project.
Yeah.
Team.
So feel free to utilize us wherever you think that we could be of any help.
OK.
I can do that. I can do that. Yeah, I appreciate that.
Yeah.
Perfect. Rest, one thing which I would like to add in case if there is anything at all, no matter how small it is, please do not wait for these calls. Me, Kip, Amit, all of us are working as a part of your extended team. So we guys are just a text away. You can always reach out to us.
Perfect.
Kip.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, Austin and Rest. I believe we are all good. Same here. Pleasure talking with you.
Okay.
Sarbjeet, it was a pleasure to meet you. Kip, good to see you again, as always.
Yep. Thank you, Austin, for your time. Have a wonderful day. Bye bye.
Thanks, gentlemen.
Take care, bye.
Bye bye.